[موسيقى]
في قرية إنجليزية هادئة شمال
لندن يعيش رجل لطالما كانت مسافة القيادة بالنسبة
له هوسًا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] قابل
بطل العالم مرتين في القيادة الطويلة
[موسيقى]
كنت طفلًا فظيعًا أعزف  المنافسات المحلية التي
كنت سأضربها هنا في
البالغين كان عمري 11 و 12 عامًا
وضربها 300 ياردة ،
يعد ميلر مسؤولاً عن بعض
أطول الرحلات التي تم تسجيلها على الإطلاق
وضرب الكرة بشكل روتيني على مسافة تزيد عن
ياردة بالحجم والسرعة التي من شأنها  ضع
حتى أمثال برايس ديشامبو للعار
، يتطلب الأمر بعض المعدات المتخصصة
في الحقيبة للحفاظ
على الأندية نفسها قانونية لاستخدامها في
أي
نوع من بيئة الجولف ، لذا فإن جولة بي جي
جولة أوروبية الخاصة بك بميداليات يوم الأحد ،
كل نوادي الجولف هذه قانونية تمامًا
لذا  الاختلافات بين سائق محترفي الجولات
التي ستكون شيئًا من هذا القبيل
وسائق محرك طويل ،
حسنًا أولاً وقبل كل شيء كما قلت إن
لديك فرقًا في الأطراف الآن من الواضح أن
سبب قيامنا بذلك هو زيادة المسافة إلى أقصى حد
لا نحاول بالضرورة ضرب
كل كرة بشكل مستقيم قدر الإمكان ،
لكننا نحاول ضرب كل كرة
طالما استطعنا ،
بينما قد تكون الأندية ومحركات الأقراص
أطول قليلاً من محترفي الجولات ،
فإن البيانات التي يتم تعقبها متطابقة تقريبًا
[  الموسيقى]
حسنًا ، دعونا نلقي نظرة على بعض
الأرقام التي نعرضها للتو ،
هناك نصف رقم لائق يبلغ 401 ياردة
لذا من الواضح أن هذا
هو ، أنت تعلم أن هذا على
الأرجح هو الهدف النهائي
آه ما ننظر إليه أولاً وقبل كل
شيء هو أشياء مثل النادي
سرعة الكرة في الرأس للقيادة الطويلة ، وخاصة
الدوران هو المفتاح ، لذا فإن مقدار دوران الكرة
للخلف ،
لذا فإن السرعة الذكية 143 ميلاً في الساعة
كانت زاوية الإطلاق حوالي 14
درجة وكان ثورًا منخفضًا يتنقل
لمسافة 401 ياردة
إنه ليس سيئًا إنه إحماء  كان معجبًا
بلقطة
مع جولة القيادة الطويلة في العالم في وضع الانتظار
لدى ميلر متسعًا من الوقت للقيام
بجولة PGA في الأسابيع الأخيرة
ولا يعتقد أن اتجاه
الضربات الطويلة في اللعبة سيتلاشى في
أي وقت قريبًا ، إنه اتجاه هائل  في الوقت
الحالي ، هذا هو الموضوع رقم واحد ،
أنت تعرف ما يفعله هؤلاء الرجال الآن ،
ما
أعنيه الرجال مثل برايسون ، خاصة أننا
نعلم جميعًا ما الذي كان ينتجه في آخر
ستة أشهر ،
وأنت تعلم أنه أخفى نفسه بعيدًا
أثناء الإغلاق ربما ذهب في صالة الألعاب الرياضية  إنه
مكتظ ثم يخرج ويتأرجح
100 سائق بأسرع ما يمكن ليس هناك
سر حقيقي لذلك هذه هي الطريقة التي
فعلناها دائمًا وهذه هي المدة
التي قام فيها السائقون بذلك ، لقد فعلنا ذلك
قليلاً  أطول مما عرفوه
في غضون 10 سنوات أو 15 عامًا
بالسيارة ، قد تكون رحلة طويلة
في الجولة التي تعرف أنها تصل إلى 150 ميلًا في
الساعة والقيادة بمعدل خمس مرات ، لا أعرف
أنك لا تعرف إلى أين تتجه  لإنهاء
ذلك سيستمر نعم